Transcriber: Mennatallah Said
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
ازيكم عاملين أيه؟
يارب تكونوا بخير وبصحة وسلامة
المحاضرة اليوم
بعنوان
قوة الإمكانات المتعددة
وفي الحقيقة، هذا العنوان
قد جاء من خلال أنني شرحت
الفكرة الخاصة بالمحاضرة
إلى شات جي بي تي
قلت له اقترح لي عنوان حلو
واقترح علي هذا العنوان الجميل
أنا لم أكن أعرف عمله بنفسي
وسنأتي لهذه في الأخر
لكن سوف أسأل سؤال الأول
هذا السؤال يقول
تخيل أنك تدرس
أربع سنين في الكلية أو خمس
أو سبع سنين في كلية
ثم تعمل في وظيفة معينة
بتبدأ أنك تخصص
وقتك كله في إنك تكتسب علم في
المسار المهني الذي تخصصت به
وتكتسب خبرة من خلال أنك
تعمل في هذه الأشياء كلها
لم تفعل أي شيء سوى أنك
أصبحت متخصص جدا
وهذا شيء جميل لا تفهمني
خطأ هذا شيء حلو
لكن تخيل بعد عشر سنين من عملك
تتفاجيء بأن المسار المهني الذي تعمل فيه
لم يعد هناك طلب عليه
ولم تعد الناس
يعني مثلا أن مترجم
حاليا الشركات بدأت تستعين
بالذكاء الاصطناعي
التعلم الآلي
في جزء أنهم يستعينوا بهذه التقنيات
إنها تترجم لهم الأشياء التي يحتاجون عملها
ونحن لا نحتاجك يا كيميا بعد الآن
فجأة هكذا استيقظ كيميا من النوم
لا يوجد شغل
لا يوجد طلب على الشغل أو
المسار المهني الخاص به
إنه يبدأ من الأول وجديد ويبدأ من الصفر
يقدر، لكن صعب جدًا
وسيكون الموضوع صعب عليه
لماذا؟
لأنها هى المهارة الوحيدة التي اكتسبها
كيميا خلال العشر سنوات الماضية بأكملها
إنه اتعلم ترجمة بشكل جيد
لكنه لم يقدر أن يضيف أي مهارات أخرى عليه
لذلك هيا نحكي القصة من أولها
حسنًا أنا أول كلية دخلتها كانت
كلية التربية قسم كيمياء وطبيعة
درست بها خمس سنوات
ثم درست في
علم الحاسوب معهد حاسب آلي
سنتين ليس أكثر والحمدلله
طلعت الأول على المعهد
بعد ذلك درست في تجارة جامعة عين شمس
لم أحبها صراحة عرفت بعض الاشياء فيها لكن
لم أحبها ولا أعرف من
الدائن ومن المدين حتى الآن
لكن فيما بعد دخلت كلية أداب ترجمة إنجليزي
وأحببت مجال الترجمة وعلم
اللغة بشكل عام أحببته جدا جدا
هذه هي الأشياء التي درستها
درستها دراسة نظامية
أما بالنسبة للشغل فأنا أول شغلانة أعمل بها
هي كانت عامل
أشتغل أشيل طوب وأسمنت
وبعد ذلك أشتغلت نقاش
أذهب وأدهن شقق وأدهن
بيوت وفيلات وأشياء مثل ذلك
وبعد ذلك أشتغلت طباخ
لكن قبل الطباخ كنت أعمل عامل نظافة
أغسل أطباق وأكواب والصحون
وبعد ذلك مساعد طباخ ثم طباخ
وبعد ذلك أشتغلت
مترجم فوري
في مصر أولا وبعد ذلك في أمريكا
وبعد ذلك أشتغلت
صانع فيديو
أقوم بعمل محتوى مقاطع مصورة على الإنترنت
على منصات فيسبوك ويوتيوب وأمازون في أمريكا
الذي أريد قوله إن
الخبرات التي تكتسبها في حياتك
لها مصدر من اثنين
المصدر الأول هو التعلم
إنك تدرس في كلية أو تأخذ دورات
أو تتعلم على الإنترنت أي شيء
المصدر الثاني هو الوظيفة
الآن أنا بسبب أنني مررت على أكثر من
مرحلة للتعلم إنني تعلمت أشياء كثيرة
ولأنني أيضًا أشتغلت في مهن كثيرة جدا
هذا الموضوع عمل معي شيء في غاية الأهمية
ألا وهي أنني قمت بعمل خطة بديلة لنفسي
هذه الخطة البديلة
إنه إذا في يوم من الأيام
المسار المهني الذي أعمل به
ومستمتع به وأكسب منه جيد جدا
فجأة أصبح لا يوجد طلب عليه
الشركات لا تحتاج الخبرة الخاصة بي لهذا
لذا فإنني لدي نقطة انطلاق
في مكان أخر في مهارة أخرى
أي أنني متعلم في فنون النقاشة
وبجانبها أعمل مترجم
فجأة شغل الترجمة انتهى
أنا أقدر بكل بساطة أنني أشتغل
نقاش لكي أعيل نفسي وأسرتي
لأنني لدي المهارة الخاصة
بأن أعمل بهذه الجزئية
حسنا نفترض لأ أنا لا أريد
أن أنزل من الترجمة للناس
مثلا مع أنها شيء أنا أحبه
لكن دعونا نذهب مثلا لجزئية
المهارة الخاصة بصناعة الفيديو
أقدر أنني أعمل مع شركة أمازون
مع شركة يوتيوب مع هذا وهذا
في مجال ثاني بحيث إنني لا أتوقف
بحيث إنني لا أتعطل
بحيث إنني لا أشعر أن الحياة انتهت
والحياة سوداء في وجههي
فجأة هكذا استيقظت من
النوم وجدت الحياة مدمرة
لماذا أتحدث في هذه النقطة؟
نحن نعيش في عالم حاليًا متغير جدًا
عالم للتو سمعنا أخبار من فترة إن جوجل
قامت بتسريح أثنى عشر ألف موظف
فيسبوك قامت بعمل تسريح
أيضًا لإحدى عشر ألف موظف
ولديك تويتر نصف موظفين الشركة تم تسريحهم
وأيضًا مايكروسوفت نفس النظام وشركات كثيرة
هذه الشركات كبيرة جدًا
ولديها أموال كثيرة جدًا
ولا يحتاجون أن يسرحوا الموظفين بسبب
أن الأموال التي لدى الشركات قلت
لا فهم يسرحونهم لأنهم قاموا
بإستبدالهم بتقنيات جديدة
أتمتة التي تعني التشغيل الآلي
أو الذكاء الاصطناعي
أو التعلم الآلي وهكذا
لذا
مهم جدًا أن يكون لديك خطة
وأن يكون لديك مهارة
أنا من الناس التي بعد أن أنتهي
من ثماني ساعات عمل لدي
أعود للمنزل وأحاول أن
أتعلم مهارة ثانية جديدة
مهارة تفيدني
يعني مؤخرًا العرض التقديمي الذي
تشاهدونه بأكلمه أعددته باستخدام كانفا
لأنني تعلمت برنامج كانفا برنامج جميل وسهل
وأقدر من خلاله عمل أشياء كثيرة حلوة
لذلك ما أريد قوله
إن موضوع أنك يكون لديك تعدد في المهارات
أو تعدد في الأشياء الخاصة بالخبرة لديك
هذه تفيدك جدًا جدًا
إنها تكون الخطة البديلة للعالم
المتغير هذا الذي أنت به
يكفي
شكرًا لكم
(تصفيق)